[Music]
[Applause]
one of the most innovative companies in
fiber in the UK is city fiber and I'm
delighted to be joined today in Valencia
by Greg mesh the CEO Greg before we
start tell us about City Fiber and what
you've already achieved yeah well it's
been a really interesting and quite a
journey where seven years old now we're
publicly listed on the London Stock
Exchange so we're under the symbol City
we've started with a model where we did
acquisitions of duct infrastructure
across those secondary cities and then
we also built duct infrastructure under
contracts with the public sector so
we've done five acquisitions nine metro
builds that's got us across 42 cities
and we have roughly 3000 kilometers of
duct and fiber infrastructure in all of
those cities we've also done two
fiber-to-the-home builds one in
Bournemouth one under a joint venture
with Sky and talk talk where we proved
all the economics the one in York we
built out over the course of roughly a
year and a half it's 14,000 homes
currently over approaching 40%
penetration in that footprint so a huge
success or we proved all the economics
and and the the quality of services and
the uptake from the consumers and then
just recently we completed a what we
view is a transformational partnership
with Vodafone
where it is potentially to build up to
20% of the UK 5 million homes and to
start with 12 cities and a million homes
and were right there at the start of
that tell us a bit more about the
Vodafone because as you say that is
really transformational yes it is in a
lot of people say that must take me a
year to get done it actually took us
seven years because we had to prove
ourselves we had to prove our
engineering skills we had to prove our
technology we had to prove that we could
do it and I think that's a huge credit
to city Fiber to be able to have
positioned ourselves in that position
but because we sit with core duct
infrastructure across 42 cities that's
already equaling roughly about 4 million
homes than what we've proven is how we
can take that core infrastructure and
rapidly roll out a fibre to the home
network or fibre to the premises network
off that Vodafone's contract with us did
two things they said number one we can't
conceive of a world where the UK has
only one fibre provider as in open reach
so we need to diversify that so having
multiple suppliers of fibre was going to
be good for everybody so the framework
is for up to 20% of the UK and to start
with no less than a million homes across
roughly 12 cities the other thing that's
transformational about that is that
because of our model and we have no
legacy infrastructure legacy assets we
can do it fast and we can do it without
any burdensome overheads or any any fear
of the copper revenue migrations and so
we can actually give a better economic
value to Vodafone so one they get a
diversify the whole supply chain in the
UK but they also get better economics to
serve their customers is there anything
that the Europe can learn from this
model well I think one of the greatest
things that we're all learning now is
that like city fiber in the UK was a
spark for the industry we have been
consistent for seven years about doing
this and you could say that the entire
move that BT open reach is beginning to
make and the the great announcement
TalkTalk made last week that they want
to do this all of those are driven off
of a spark and we are that spark that
helped to drive that but I think the
real message is and that it seems to be
lost on a lot but because we have no
legacy infrastructure we have no legacy
systems we're not trapped behind the
copper revenue dilemma we can quickly
roll out cities fall over build cities
and we can do it at a better economic
value than anybody else so the alternate
operators are really where the
government's and the regulators should
focus because if they focus their
attention on helping somebody
demonstrate 10 20 30 percent of their
market more efficiently than it will
drive the incumbents to build more
efficiently supply better quality
services at lower costs for everybody in
the market so I really think the lesson
is is that it requires sparks in each of
these countries and those sparks are
usually their alternate operators Gregg
thank you very much for talking to us
thank you
so City Fiber a spark for Europe
[Music]
you